it's the family photo during the summer
treatment
[Music]
yeah and that's a pixelated crotch
stealing the show no I'm laughing
because of the pixelation
Kelly Ripa laughs herself to tears after
seeing hubby Mark consuelos's package
blurred out on Live with Kelly and Mark
no turning back now no turning
background speaking of turning back
let's rewind and explain how Mark ended
up in need of some extra coverage in the
first place I just want to be hopefully
value added to the show it all started
when Mark was doing just that giving
viewers an inside look into his recent
trip to Italy where he visited a soccer
team that he and Kelly recently
purchased a stake in we've always worked
together in some capacity and while the
52 year old was getting in on the action
by kicking a ball he injured himself
even a physical therapist needed to
treat him so uh very embarrassing I hurt
myself
kicking the ball so I'm here with the
physio for our soccer team
he's gonna try to fix me up we'll see if
he can do it and good news that physical
therapist did fix him and so did an
editor as a TV personality signed
autographs and took photos while being
treated you could see pixelated cubes
blurring out his crotch during every
move something Kelly found hilarious so
we're going to show some more tomorrow
of the actual game and are you playing
no I'm laughing because of the
pixelation the pixelation of your crotch
they didn't need to pixelated
if you see some you know if it's tight
shirts I figured I might you know just
to play it safe sounds like Mark is
looking to keep playing it safe on the
talker which Echoes what he told ET when
he officially nabbed the live co-host
gig it's the number one show in daytime
and don't want to screw that up
um so you know when a team wins the
championship the only place to go is you
know they just want to keep winning
championships so I just want to be
hopefully value added to the show well
you got your a team here and Kelly Ripa
that's correct you know what I mean by
Tom Brady but sometimes even the goats
have hiccups on live TV
look at my dress rip open last month it
was Kelly's almost wardrobe malfunction
that took Center Stage when she thought
her dress ripped wide open during a
dance segment a moment she and Mark
handled like pros
rip open
no just a little bit it's just a
breakaway dress
okay okay
do you wanna who cares it's been almost
a month since Mark replaced Ryan
Seacrest to work alongside Kelly as
co-host and it's obvious the couple who
recently celebrated 27 years of marriage
are still going strong I mean Mark's
been filling in here I've been here for
almost 23 years he's been filling in for
that long
um so it's been a long time you told me
just to be myself yeah enjoy the moment
one show at a time just like we always
do
foreign
[Music]